hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report oh yeah we're in Rio de Janeiro
oh yeah I wore my strong bikini on beach
well the bottom parts out the whole
bikini I'm not that woke Stacy I hope
everybody enjoyed our New Year's Eve
specials with gerald Celente and michael
hudson we had two specials in the new
year those were back in the northern
hemisphere that we recorded with them
but we're still here in the southern
hemisphere and I have some headlines I'd
like to look at you know looking into
2020 now that we are officially there
BBC fight back over election savaging as
Chiefs plan to increase broadcast from
Midlands and the north
BBC Chiefs are planning a big expansion
of broadcast from outside of London to
assuage critics as they came under fire
today from both sides of the new House
of Commons the corporation is aiming to
demonstrate that it is listening to the
whole of Britain following the general
election campaign when it was accused of
glossing over the strong views of leave
voters in the north and even of letting
its impartiality slip oh no the
impartiality slip BBC right well I read
in the Tory manifesto that Boris Johnson
wants to try to encourage the BBC to
take more of the government line and to
make it more organ of the government
officially in Oregon the government wait
is now it's kind of unofficially the
organ of the government I think for me
that is quite important about this is
something you and I have observed it's
something we've said on Kai's report
we've said it on all sorts of media
outlets social media our blog or things
like that so that we've discussed that
is that we have the same problem in
America all of the presenters on the
mainstream news on the cable news are
centred entirely out of New York
entirely out of Washington DC all the
newspapers across America we used to
have local television we just have local
newspapers we have used to have regional
newspapers regional press outlets now we
only have from the major financial
centers and it reminded me of a contact
I have in the intelligence community I
know that's big now in these days I
would be a hero
on MSNBC but he was telling me that
under Dick Cheney that Dick Cheney was
really furious when the intelligence
community basically did not agree that
their al-qaeda was working in Iraq and
that Saddam Hussein's was friends with
Iraq with al-qaeda and that there were
WMDs there so he basically got rid of
all the agents in the field and the
reason why he did that is he said they
had gone native and they had too much
sympathy with the natives and that they
needed to just have the Imperial line
and said so it strikes me as that's very
similar to a scene in the media space is
that we haven't had anybody child we
don't have Rachel Maddow when was the
last time she ever left New York City or
Manhattan right she doesn't have the
perspective and that's why they miss it
that's why they failed so much and had
to concoct then all these conspiracy
theories to explain away their failure
to see what was going to happen in 2016
or with brexit and johnson being
reelected to the to the prime
ministership like they missed all that
well in the u.s. i mean you used to have
more regional media hubs and local media
hubs and stories would make their way
from local news to national news but now
it's all based on three or four major
corporations I think actually there's
six major corporations that own all the
news and so they don't really pay any
attention to anything outside of the
were those people who are clustered or
live in those areas and as part of a
function of the way that we've seen all
its consolidation and the abandonment of
news as information gathering and
dissemination of truth and in more of as
a product like cheese that's sold by the
pound but that notion of being concerned
by whether it's the vice president in
the case of the intelligence community
or the corporations that financed MSNBC
and Fox and CNN being concerned if the
presenters are have gone gone native if
they if they are too sympathetic to the
ordinary person then that doesn't work
does it because then they can't sell the
Lockheed Martin and Boeing ads against
Rachel Maddow Show they can't sell war
they can't
sell these things like they have to
abide by whatever the you know the
corporate line is hello there is stark
it's true right you've got this idea as
you point out the anecdotally Cheney
fired all the CIA agents in the field
because they were too sympathetic to the
locals and he felt that was a liability
in the major media spheres in Washington
in DC they don't want those reporters
those stars to rub elbows in the great
unwashed of the flyover States because
they may become sympathetic to the
working class they may become
sympathetic to the to the
disenfranchised in America so they keep
them in their little bubble and this I
guess is what we're seeing over at the
BBC they they they suggest that these
stars that are paid enormous amounts of
money in in the UK should go out there
and actually talk to real people but if
they were to do that they might actually
become sympathetic to the plight of
those real people and that could be a
problem in getting the official
propaganda message over the line and
it's very strange that we've seen since
especially 2016 when both the brakes at
vote and the Trump vote happened and the
elite who are again are in the capital
city they're not on the ground they're
not seeing or talking to the deplorable
z-- right so since then we've seen this
fake news and what Dick Cheney for
example what he wanted at that time in
the lead-up to the invasion of Iraq was
fake news he wanted a dodgy dossier
he wanted a sexed-up dossier you
remember he wanted to sell the war here
the same thing they want to sell war
that's why MSNBC and Fox do they sell
war and if you're talking to people on
the ground who if you talk to people on
the ground they they want an end of
globalization at this point it's too
fast and furious it's too much war it's
too much poverty for the bottom with the
top running away with all the
quantitative easing funds yeah I find a
remarkable I just read it this statistic
on this recently something like 40 or 50
of the talking heads on MSNBC and these
other cable outlets actually are current
or former CIA operatives so that's if
that's not a that's government that's
amount
piece of the in this case the deep state
and this is why there's so much
confusion with this impeachment circus
going on because the media is not
independent they're mouthing the talking
points of the deep state we're gonna see
continuation of this fake news theme
going into 2020 because there is another
election and you know even the polls are
showing that Trump can beat all of these
you know it back in 2016 they didn't but
still because they will refuse in the
United States they will refuse in the
cable news to go native to see the
deplorable to talk to the to follow
deplorable to even understand the
deplorable they'll they'll Rachel Maddow
won't leave Manhattan that's my
prediction for 2020 she'll stay there
and she'll pontificate from there and
she'll shout at people from there
but I also want to now talk about 2020
in terms of the stock market because
2019 ended with a remarkable story I
felt because there was record outflows
from mutual funds and ETFs US equity
fund flows 2019 has seen the largest
outflows from US equity mutual funds and
ETFs and 28 years this 340 billion in
total meanwhile the sp500 is be in the
MSCI world excluding us index by 20
percent since the 2018 started so
relp i looked at this data and he says
welcome to the outside effects of
passive indexation the market still goes
up into massive outflow he says active
strategy cell ie the baby boomers are
retiring and selling at all-time highs
and passive buys I the 401ks and stuff
like that are driving the index higher
and taking an ever larger share of the
market let's put this into context
there's a lot of talk now about how
social media platforms like Facebook and
and others rely on algorithms and these
algorithms are programmed to exclude
certain talking points and discussion
points to emphasize others they appear
to be in the province of the management
of these huge corporations that have
their own agenda it's not in the public
good but this word algorithm has become
very fashionable now we've been talking
about on this show for many years but
now you find Hollywood celebrities and
Talking Heads talking about the
algorithms okay
the fact is that algorithms on Wall
Street as well well eighty to ninety
percent of the volume is by robot and a
lot of the stories that the robots key
upon are written by algorithms like
Forbes uses digitally assisted editorial
mechanical robots to write stories based
on prices and they fill in the narrative
and then the robots look at what the
robots wrote and then the robots buy and
sell that changes prices then the robots
comment on the price change and then the
robots on the training floor look at
what the robots wrote about the price
change and then they buy and sell again
so it's this daisy chain or mobius strip
of AI of algorithms feeding on each
other and so it would with that story
there the algorithms are showing that
the market is moving up which is drawing
in a lot of passive money the pension
money that must invest based on
algorithms there's no human there and so
the robots are buying all these stocks
meanwhile the humans the people who look
at the market in terms of the price to
earnings ratio priced of market
capitalization ratios are dumping
they're getting out of the market the
luckiest generation ever to stock
American history the boomer and
generation is getting out at all-time
highs
thanks to quantitative easing it's it's
the Millennials and younger who are
buying this their passive funds are
buying that and now finally speaking of
Rachel Maddow for one of her biggest
sponsors certainly of MSNBC's Boeing
Boeing is a huge defense contractor in
America but they also make planes that
fly that fall out of the air Boeing
shares tumble after companies to spend
737 max production so that suspended
they're going to have to wait probably
until March or April to get any FAA
approval for speaking of algorithms this
is a plane that structurally cannot fly
it can't fly on its own it needs
software and an algorithm in order to
make it airworthy because of the design
flaws of the actual plane so they're
waiting for you know the the FAA to
approve this I want to point out when
this stock price tumble is is still over
300 which is up nearly three and two
fold since Trump came into office so you
can see like as soon as Trump came into
office as spikes because there has
a huge increase in the budget for the
military-industrial complex I'm trying
so algorithms destroy the public
discourse over social media algorithms
destroy the public marketplace by
relying on robots to talk about and then
trade stocks and so the aviation
industry is saying hold my beer let's
take these algorithms and put them in
charge of flying our airplanes and if
people fly out of the sky they crashed
out of the sky well it's not our fault
it's the algorithms fault it's the robot
blame Robbie the robot not us that the
CEO of Boeing win nothing to do with it
before the end of 2019 there was some
sort of leak of information or some data
that came out of the FAA who are the
regulators for the airline industry in
America there's supposed to be the
regulators and it showed that they knew
that this plane the 737 max had problems
with flying and they expected there to
be one or two crashes every three years
so they already they knew this and they
took this as part of their their
willingness to you know keep up the
share price I didn't want to impact the
company member under the holder doctrine
like they say these regulators stay up
late at night if they think that the
stock price are these CEOs and and the
executive suites they might lose some
income or options trading you know
that's you know they put people on the
board who maybe came from the ice cream
industry that they can accept certain
number of rat hairs per kilogram of ice
cream so it's acceptable in the
manufacturing process they figure okay
some of these planes are gonna fall out
of the sky and few hundred people will
die but that's an acceptable risk to hit
our profit margins get people on your
board who value human life
Boeing how to be a good first step stay
tuned after the break we have Jimi song
from Uruguay don't go away
welcome back to the Kaiser report on Max
Keiser time now to turn to Jimi song who
is an author and he's also well very
well known in the Bitcoin space Jimmy
welcome back thanks for having me again
alright so yeah I mentioned you're an
author you've written I think two books
on this right well what are these two
books it is programming Bitcoin it's for
developers if that want to learn about
Bitcoin it teaches you everything that
you need to know to learn the Bitcoin
blockchain the other book is the little
Bitcoin book it's meant more for a lay
audience that doesn't know anything
about that coin they can learn all about
it
or if you already know Bitcoin this is a
good way to save time when explaining it
to your relative that knows nothing
about it all right perfect so we are in
Montenegro we are in Montevideo Uruguay
and that the Latin American Bitcoin
conference or la bit Kampf
and you gave a very compelling talk and
at the centerpiece of that talk was
something called the can tell in effect
which we mentioned on this show quite
often and as a Bitcoin mat guy I don't
say maximalist but I know you can I
don't think that's an insult okay as a
Bitcoin maximalist ona has been really
deep dive into this space for a while
talk about it because it's I think this
is a concept that really needs to be
understood in a broader sense yeah
so the the can't tell on can't tell I
can tell you can tell on effect is
essentially this effect named after this
economist Richard Cantillon who's a
French Irish economist from the 1700s
who noticed that with the Bank of
England the people that first got the
newly printed money got all of the
benefits and and what I've noticed as
I've studied the various effects of that
from the US dollar is that you know
largely they benefit a lot of rich
people big companies you know we are
talking earlier about nationalization
essentially of a lot of companies
through these central banks that are
taking on some of the stock on balance
sheets and so on but that's who benefits
it's it's the people that get to spend
it first and you can always kind of see
it with the interest rates that they're
getting all of the US dollars are debt
at this point so whoever
it gets a lower interest rate they're
the people that get the most amount of
benefit out of it and who are those
people well it's it's the big companies
that are getting you know 0.5% and it's
the bankers that you know get to print
that money and make all of this money
essentially for free right I mean to put
it in simple terms it's almost like
living upstream mmm you get the clean
water you know and as the water flows
down it gets dirtier and dirtier and so
if you live near a central bank and the
zip codes around the Federal Reserve
Bank in Washington are very very rich
how interesting and they tend to be the
industries that get the first dibs on
the money tends to be very rich the
hedge fund industry we have a one hedge
fund a guy New York just bought at an
apartment for 250 million dollars right
so he's that's money that's essentially
just being piped in from the central
bank into his property speculation and
by the way he just put one a former
central banker on his board
right so there's a very close
relationship there so how does this
relate to Bitcoin in terms of money
because actually I was reading that some
Austrian economists are also critical
disk until an effect hmm and so of
course that's another theme here and at
the conference is Austrian economics and
Austrian economics interestingly enough
Bitcoin is legitimized it in a way it
had been overridden by Keynesianism and
overridden by the Paul Krugman's of the
world but it's made a huge comeback
because of the things predicted about
currencies competing with each other and
a multitude of currencies out there is
there a connection do you see that
connection and as a technologist he said
how do you find it interesting that
you've now gotten into the realm of
economic theory and how do those two
things work together yeah I never would
have imagined that this is the direction
that I would have gone down when I
started my programming career like 20
years ago but unfortunately that's kind
of where it's led and and I have studied
a lot more Austrian economics especially
since 2008 and I have noticed that you
know a lot of the predictions of
Austrian economic business cycle theory
malinvestments leading to all sorts of
you know bad effects in the economy and
stuff like that where we've been seeing
that
since 2008 bad investments are now
investments because the money it just
flows into the pockets of those near the
money he's not based on the fact that
they're smarter or building anything
that's creating jobs he's not going to
have a proximity to the money and this
crowds out mmm good businesses and good
banks yeah and and you know like instead
of capital capital accumulation right
now you have just that base growth so
right whoever can get access to that
debt at the cheapest price and the price
is not determined by current savings its
newly printed money or what at what rate
you can get those and that those are
inevitably the big companies or trickled
down through VC money towards startups
and things like that so you you have all
sorts of perverse incentives in the
economy and and that causes these giant
corporations that are like not feeling
at all you know like they're way too big
to feel anything really but they end up
abusing the system for their own benefit
and lining the pockets of people in the
cities like New York and London you
wonder why those two cities for example
are prosperous is because their
financial centers it's because they
they're near the money like you said now
another financial center that's
experiencing quite a different reaction
right now would be Hong Kong mmm it
seems like the can't effect is operating
in a big time and I'm going with the
prices of property just skyrocketing and
there's a not trickling down and is that
now what the future of these other
financial centers can look for is is
Hong Kong kind of the canary in a coal
mine here it could be it's alright hard
for us to say and I'm sure it'll be a
lot clearer in retrospect but yeah
there's a store of value premium on
almost every asset that exists right now
which which is kind of scary because
that means that instead of things being
valued for their utility like a house is
valuable because you can you know rent
it out or live in it or whatever instead
there's an additional premium on top of
that a four-story value because there's
no good store of value in the world
today I mean other than Bitcoin which is
making
but because of that these resources end
up going to people that want to store
value instead of people that want to use
it and that that means that it crowds
out people that want to buy homes to
live in instead it's going to people
that want to invest it's it's gotten so
crazy that in China you know second
homes there are more people buying
second homes that first homes they're
not living in them probably and there
are entire ghost cities of apartments
because the Chinese government feels the
need to have more assets that people can
invest it and I mean that's absolutely
crazy so 1971 Nixon severs the
connection between gold and the u.s.
dollar effectively defaulting on
sovereign debt in America and shortly
thereafter with all that fiat money
around the u.s. decides to go on a
colonialization spree in overthrowing
the government in Chile Owens knowing
the government in Argentina and always
fiat money mm-hmm now slice forward to
2019 2020 populations here for my
observation particularly in Argentina
seemingly believe that bitcoin is the
way out of this then hard money we can
we can we can get rid of these colonial
u.s. masters mm-hmm and adoption rates
are quite high what what it would have
been your observations anything similar
to that or what do you that today yeah I
mean all around the world I think
everyone kind of has this idea that
there is a dollar hegemony that the
dollar controls everything that there's
a monetary imperialism that the u.s. is
essentially you know putting out to
everybody else they can you know for
example enforce sanctions in or on Iran
because they anybody that does business
they're gonna have to have some sort of
banking relationship and any bank needs
a relationship with the US Fed in some
way and if you cut that off they run out
of business or they go out of business
so that has been the method of control
and you can see that the inflation sort
of gets exported to a lot of these
third-world countries or in Latin
America especially and you you get
hyperinflation because they really have
no other choice
in terms of like balancing their books
or something like that so talk to
anybody in these countries they
understand the doll
hegemony almost right away and they
understand that bitcoin is a politically
neutral money it's it's the money of
peace as you would say and that causes
them to get it much faster than say a
Silicon Valley insider that thinks
bitcoin is some tech play and it needs
to you know there's better bitcoins that
are coming so I better invest in them or
something like that instead it's like
yeah I get it it's it's a politically
neutral money it's it's something that I
can store my value in and I don't have
to you know like you know be abused by
my government who's oppressing me
through monetary means all right I
should mention there's some sirens in
the background that's what that's all
about now you mentioned that everything
is being treated as a store of value hmm
and the utility values being overwritten
and ignored so let's talk about your hat
for a second typically we would buy as
utility uh-huh to keep the Sun from your
eyes or to keep the rain off your face
and yet you've seemed to turn this into
a little bit of a cottage industry
auctioning off your hat again so you're
buying these hats for as a store value
because you're auctioning them off
presumably a bit higher price and you're
buying them at but so this whole trend
toward commodification and the ignoring
utility value has extended to your
chapeau try to follow and they can tell
in effect the linguistic paradigm here
tell us more about that when will this
hat be auctioning off and how's that
business going to be well I guess you're
calling me out for being a scammer and I
I think I'm gonna have to kind of agree
a little bit here but it's for good
cause max it's for a good cause
no I'm not I'm not suggesting that I'm
saying that it's a great example of
exactly what you're talking about people
look at the world in terms of what the
resale value is on yeah that's good then
nothing has utility anymore and that
extends socially into the family hmm and
some of the institutions that have been
responsible for social cohesion
we're being ripped apart at the seams
and by this trend toward the
modification a merely to fast rate Jamie
because you're like what's this bag
going on
absolutely it there there is sort of
like this thing where people think in
terms of what resale value that they're
going to get and how much value they're
storing and stuff even even people that
are hoarders it's it's kind of a you
know a consequence of that effect
they're they're thinking they're they're
not hoarding necessarily - why I mean
it's a mental disorder and stuff like
that but they're the justification is
usually about resale price of these
things yeah and in that sense it's it's
that way - but but yeah even even stuff
like my hat or whatever people do think
in terms of how much can I sell it for
later and there is a desire to store
value but because fiat money is so bad
at it when nothing is a I mean when when
nothing is a good sorbet everything
takes on some of the Soraa value
characteristics and having a separation
I think would be very good because then
you start thinking of things in terms of
utility and what you need and how you
can make more money doing a business or
being an entrepreneur or find providing
value and so on and that's that's very
good for civilization that adds good new
goods and services whereas you know like
a fiat mentality is I need to get my
share and I need to make sure that I'm
not screwed when you know blah blah blah
and that that's a much better mentality
for everyone to have I think yeah that's
a good point
yeah all right well thanks for being on
the cars report thanks for every week
all right that's gonna do it for this
edition of the Kaiser report with me Max
Keiser I stay sir we'd like to thank our
guest jimmy song author and Bitcoin
influencer until next time just want to
catch us on Twitter it's guys report
until then bye y'all
[Music]